ball superstar in the world of
gymnastics and she
decided midway through her team
competition to step away
to take time out after a very uh
on below par first vault that she had
she just said she wasn't
in the right space she couldn't mentally
work and push herself in the way that
she normally does
and so she decided to take herself out
of the competition
it threw enormous drama into that and gb
actually picked up a bronze a very
unexpected bronze in that team
gymnastics women's competition and a lot
of discussion now around
mental health the issues that we've
heard ventilated
through the course of this year over and
over again as to the pressure
these athletes are under and how they
are coping with it and simone biles late
last night in tokyo gave a news
conference explaining her decision
saying that she just wasn't quite ready
to put herself
in danger by doing the kind of
extraordinary moves that she normally
does
and also she wouldn't jeopardize her
team's chances of a medal
and it's been really stressful this
olympic games i think just as a whole
um not having an audience there are a
lot of different variables going into it
it's been
a long week it's been a long olympic
process it's been a long
year so just a lot of different
variables and i think
we're just a little bit too stressed out
but we should be out here having fun and
sometimes that's not the case
so that is something that will be
discussed for quite a while simone bars
does have a chance to come back in the
individual competition
here in the gymnastics will she do that
or will she decide that
she's not in the right place to do it
who knows the skills that she's
competing
if you get lost in the middle of that
skill it could just
it's like not just a career that end an
injury it could be a life threatening
injury
and nothing's worth that no result or no
medals worth that i'm so proud of her
for making the right decision
her mental health and her safety should
always come first